the favelas of Rio De Janeiro slums on
the hillsides around the city are
dangerous places you need permission to
enter Outsiders are welcome
these are the most marginalized
communities in the country little social
care and little investment
cable car built for the Olympics is
abandoned and broken
bullet holes from gang fights pepper the
building
beneath it gerasi Gomez runs her Cafe
helped by her husband Claudio and her
grandson Gilbert
their business thrived when the cable
car worked now they struggle
there are millions like them unsure what
is going to happen and scared of
political violence
[Music]
foreign
you think these people would naturally
lean towards potentially left-wing
government but the divisiveness of this
election and indeed Society in general
means that isn't necessarily the case
fact is an awful lot of people in these
communities in the favelas which are
basically slums don't vote quite often
it's not because they're not interested
in politics it's because getting down to
the voting stations
is expensive most of them have to
continue working they're really really
poor but getting those people to vote
could be the key to what happens in this
election it's those people who have yet
to vote or haven't yet decided maybe the
difference between either of the two
candidates winning this election
local politicians have until the end of
the month to convince the electorate
cosme phillipsson is in Lula de Silva's
party he'll be knocking doors trying to
convince people to get on board for the
second round opportunities
Brazilian
Lula is ahead and president baldinaro is
only just behind they know their
constituencies are with them it's the
undecided and marginalized who will hold
the balance of power
Stewart Ramsey Sky News Rio de Janeiro